hast du es mitbekommen mit Madison Bier
das jetzt Single ist
echt ja es wurden ja chatverläufe gelegt
aber das hast du mitbekommen oder wo die
mit diesem Instagram Typen da
geschrieben hat nee laserluca
ich würde es so feiern wenn du auf ernst
und wir zusammen wärst
zusammen wäre ich würde jeden Tag 10
Stunden sage ich mir das so ich habe ab
18 Uhr Zeit für dich erstmal zehn
Stunden beten dass du überhaupt hier
bist die hat jetzt mit Twitch angefangen
ne ja habe ich auch gesehen da Laser
nicht so gerne in den Twitch
man darf bis jetzt ziemlich scheiße
[Musik]
explodiert Creeper komm mal komm mal
komm mal komm nicht ich bin hier
[Musik]
keine Sorge dass unsere Welt die Luft
springt einfach abhaus ich mache mir
doch gar nichts aus ich reg mich da auch
nicht alles gut ja du hast dich schon
genug gerecht heute ein paar Sekunden
später ich glaube wir hören oder
[Musik]
ich bin so schön dass Sandras Mikro
einfach ausgeht wenn sie übersteuert
hört man die einfach nicht mehr das
war's das war's das war's das war's
Sandy ich lösche es doch gerade
gesammelt habe kann ich jetzt einfach
wieder hier reinsetzen wieder neu laufen
tut mir leid kann man nichts machen
[Musik]
na gut
was sagen wir zu rammstein
ja Katastrophe also an alle die das
Thema nicht mitbekommen haben guckt euch
mal das Video von Kayla an ich habe
irgendwie auch tiktok Ausschnitte
gesehen dass Leute trotzdem immer noch
zum Rammstein Konzert gehen was ich
nicht verstehe Alter verkauft alle eure
Karten bitte oder gibt die einfach
kostenlos ab muss das Wort jetzt leider
sagen aber es leider echt ein Huso
alterste deutsche Band eigentlich auch
international ziemlich krass vertreten
wir haben ja selber mal gesagt dass er
eigentlich hatten damals im Podcast mal
gesagt dass das gerne anschauen würden
so ein Konzert weil die ja sehr krass
sein sollen mit so Feuerwerk und allen
möglichen mittlerweile bin ich da auch
eher von abgeneigt Leute müssen wir das
Thema noch mal zusammenfassen für euch
alles klar es geht um den Sänger den
Lied Sänger von Rammstein namens Till
Lindemann glaube ich heißt ja da kam
jetzt so mehr und mehr Mädels an die
Öffentlichkeit die gesagt haben ja der
hat uns vergewaltigt hat uns Drogen ins
Glas getan der hat uns unter die Bühne
gezerrt und dann irgendwie zu sexuellen
Sachen gezwungen also wirklich keine
schönen Sachen und auch einfach
Gewalttaten Straftaten die dort
anscheinend passiert sind das kam jetzt
alles ans Tageslicht und wir haben mehr
Youtuber oder zum Video gemacht ich weiß
jetzt nicht ich hatte gesehen dass rezo
oder zu anderen Video gemacht hat ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob der auch Kontakt mit
Till Lindemann hatte oder ob er nur die
Sachen zusammengefasst hatte aber er ist
ja er kann sowas ja super gut
zusammenfassen weißt du okay aber da kam
jetzt nichts großartig neues oder wie
ich habe mir das Video von rieselt ich
habe mir äh direkt das Video von keiner
reingezogen
an alle Leute zieht euch zieht euch das
wirklich mal rein das ist so krass ganz
kurze Kurzfassung ja hatten wir gerade
schon gesagt einfach das sexuelle
Straftaten begangen wurden von dem
Sänger und das ist immer so
weggeschwiegen wurde es wird dafür auch
Beweise geben das ist auch klar weil die
sich in alle Richtungen abgesichert
haben allein dass die ganzen Mädels da
abgeben und so ne ja allein dass die
Mädels die Handys abgeben mussten dass
da überall Securitys standen und dann
mit KO-Tropfen dass sie sich auch nicht
erinnern das ist halt brutal ist halt
brutale einfach ich hoffe einfach
dass einer der Security Männer oder
sonst was dazu Statement angibt und die
Wahrheit rausbricht weißt du nee die
werden auch alle Sachen unterschrieben
haben oder so ich glaube nicht dass da
was passieren wird leider ähm man kann
man es ihm wahrscheinlich mit richtigen
beweisen nicht nachweisen dass so etwas
passiert ist und es wird wahrscheinlich
so typisch wie das Internet ist in zwei
Wochen wieder wer neues durch den Stall
gejagt und in einem Jahr geht wieder
jeder zu einem Rammstein Konzert es wird
so sein aber ich hoffe dass da
vielleicht irgendwie was rauskommen wird
oder so
warten das schlimmste was ich dieses
Jahr gehört habe no joke ja so an
Skandal Sachen es ist schon irre ne wenn
dann Leute irgendwie auf tik Tokio
gemacht Blabla so das sind halt wirklich
schlimme Sachen die da passiert sind
wirklich traumatische Erlebnisse so und
da gehört es sich auch mal darüber
wirklich krass zu berichten aber wenn
ich mir da so Sachen angucke bei tiktok
wenn der wieder mit dem Streit hat oder
so das ist nichts im Gegensatz zu
solchen Sachen noch ein paar Fackeln ja
habe ich werfen wir mal zwei rüber
Fackeln guck mal wie schön mein Bett
dreh dich um
[Musik]
weißt du wie das aussieht
wie unserem Pharao wenn der Tod ist
sondern Pyramide ja du sollst auch wirk
en was
[Musik]
lass uns jetzt sein
Hausverbot erteilen
[Musik]
verpiss dich das war's jetzt wir gehen
jetzt Mario Party Mario Kart
[Musik]
ich glaube wirklich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja okay das war es mit Minecraft danke
schön fürs zuschauen war sehr lustig
[Musik]